welcome back to CBS mornings we're
looking at a medical coding change that
could limit options for some women
fighting breast cancer each year more
than a hundred thousand women in the U.S
need a mastectomy after a breast cancer
diagnosis the Women's Health and cancer
Rights Act requires insurance companies
who pay for mastectomies to cover breast
reconstruction as well well today in our
series medical price roulette we're
looking at how policy changes could deny
some women a more natural type of breast
reconstruction which they believed can
help field help them feel whole again
our consumer investigative correspondent
Anna Werner is here anna good morning
good morning Michelle this breast
reconstruction method uses a patient's
own tissues instead of artificial
implants something many women prefer
some surgeons say what sounded like a
simple change to the coding of this
procedure now could make it unaffordable
for all but the wealthiest patients
I noticed a small nodule like right on
my breast when the lump in Rita Davis's
breast turned out to be malignant she
and her husband Britt had no idea it
would mean more than a year-long fight
against aggressive cancer we found out
that there was much more spread than we
knew I wasn't ready for that yeah
doctors had to remove her right breast
and give and give chemotherapy and
radiation this teacher and mother of
four lost her hair her nails and her
sense of self everything is so
uncontrollable to you as the patient
you're not in control you're not in
control everything is something that
happens to you right so when doctors
asked if she wanted a breast
reconstruction she answered yes
reconstruction at least you get to have
some sort of a choice you get to have
some sort of a say of what's happening
to you and your body at that point most
women undergoing breast reconstruction
get implants made of silicone and filled
with either a silicone gel or saline
solution they carry risks of additional
surgeries pain rupture even and
Associated immune system cancer yet this
Middle School teacher knew from her own
research there was another option
something called a deep flap in which a
surgeon removes skin fat and blood
vessels from a woman's stomach
essentially doing a tummy tuck and uses
them to create a new breast with the
woman's own tissues what did you like
about what you read about it using my
own skin I liked that it would
be built naturally you know what I mean
more naturally than with implants but
when the couple went to a local plastic
surgeon's office they said oh look these
are your implants I mean they pulled out
the two the latest so let us feel them
so literally it was okay implants that
was the only direction that you got yes
the only other surgeon she could find in
San Antonio who offered deep flap
surgery didn't take her insurance their
cash price fifty thousand dollars and I
don't think that's fair I mean I don't
think that especially after fighting
this kind of a journey this kind of a
battle to be told because you don't have
the money
you don't have the option to do anything
different because this doesn't seem
right something something something's
not adding up here women should not be
asked to pay cash for this surgery say
I'm going to take all of this tissue
Austin Texas surgeon Dr Elizabeth Potter
who specializes in deep flap surgeries
says part of the problem is that the
operation is longer and requires complex
microsurgical skills meaning many
plastic surgeons simply don't offer it
on top of that some doctors charge much
higher fees and won't accept Insurance
you're already seeing where surgeons
are basically saying to patients either
you pay cash or it's not going to happen
I am already seeing that Dr Potter does
accept insurance but now she says a
change in the way the government codes
the procedure is about to make the
surgery even harder to get the change
has prompted some insurance companies to
start sending out letters like these
saying their reimbursements will drop
some she estimates by 80 percent make no
mistake women who want this surgery and
have money will always have access to it
the only people that this coding change
affects and hurts are women who need
access through insurance and if I can't
afford to pay for it myself
good luck that says Florida
representative Debbie Wasserman Schultz
a breast cancer survivor is not a good
enough answer so much of the aftermath
as you go through the process of being a
Survivor turns on your psychological
well-being and how you feel as as a
human and as a woman and this obstacle
was put in the way
of breast cancer survivors so why did
that change happen the center for
Medicare and Medicaid services the
government agency that oversees the
coding says the code changes came about
after the American Medical Association
and plastic surgeons asked for changes
but the doctors groups told us the
insurance companies are to blame for
deciding to lower their reimbursements
regardless of who's to blame this
representative is pushing for a solution
they got to get together and fix this
this is a devastating decision for women
who've been through this
representative Wasserman Schultz is part
of a bipartisan effort to get this
change reversed we contacted several
insurance companies one told us it has
now postponed lowering its
reimbursements because of the concerns
raised others didn't respond as for Rita
Davis she was lucky she found Dr Potter
who agreed to do her surgery for
whatever amount Davis's insurance will
pay even though Dr Potter says it will
not cover her costs wow but there's not
a lot of Surgeons out there doing those
kinds of almost pro bono efforts how do
we get here I mean how did this happen
you know that's a great question because
the answer to that is a little unclear
you know there's a coding process that
the government it involves doctors the
AMA the doctors groups the government
officials and they established the codes
and then the reimbursement comes from
the insurance companies who look at the
codes and decides okay it's codex that
pays this amount of money right so
essentially you kind of have it moving
from one code that paid more to another
code that paid less and nobody's really
clear on why how was this intended
unintended consequences of a change so
then what you have is you have
representative Wasserman Schultz saying
and others in Congress saying all right
you know what this is not okay whatever
the whatever the intent was the reason
was it's not okay for this to wind up
this way and you guys need to come
together and fix this and by the way
representative Wasserman Schultz says
she does not think legislation is the
answer because she's like look that's a
hard you know uphill battle it's going
to take forever if it even gets in they
need to get to come to the table and fix
it yeah yeah doing stories like this
help yeah I hope so